the new Fifty Shades movie hits theaters
this weekend in case you were wondering
why there was a buzzing sound coming
from your mom's locked bedroom in an
interesting wrinkle the cast has been
forbidden from talking about kinky sex
during press interviews so without the
sex Fifty Shades is just a movie about a
boring man and a woman who sometimes sit
in a helicopter I don't know that's
about it this is even more surprising
because the movie co-stars Marcia Gay
Harden whose name already sounds like a
sex thing how would you describe BDSM
sex in a family-friendly way
JJ sticks and stones may break my bones
but it's the only way I can come anymore
all right points Annie it's about love
leather and women sliding off their
seats at movie theater yeah yeah ooh man
that's what you meant
Josh what do you what do you think I
look kids I have an anger problem so
it's either you or your dad
[Music]
[Applause]